how old are your kids now they look like
they're two or something there's five in
five and six we are not going insane I
mean what the [ __ ] are you doing
it's like it's a lot I gotta say thank
God for Nancy but I mean like it's
homeschooling is just I don't know I
don't remember Spanish I don't know
Spanish
yeah I'm neither you teaching the kids I
know you don't know anything you go how
to do it just like it's a lot of a lot
of change really quick by hopefully by
next week it'll be normally like the new
normal but right now it's it's insane I
go between that and the show it's a lot
of the whole days packed I've never I
feel like I've never worked this hard
and I think you should teach your
children when you do your when you do
your homeschooling I think you should do
it in a sandler type of voice how good
of a day how good of a dad are you like
how did you explain to your two sweet
little girls about the quarantine and
the virus like what are you doing do you
remember like mr. wizard yes of course
Don Herbert mr. wizard
thank you see behind your toes he loves
with love that [ __ ] I like a tiny bowl
and I put water and I sprinkled pepper
into the dish right and I said this is
the coronavirus I said no stick your
finger in the dish of water they did and
there you go all right now put your
finger in this dish of soapy water they
did that ago now put your finger back
into the pepper and you remember that if
you do that the pepper spreads away
right and they thought it was a magic
trick time oh I'm like that's what soap
does to the virus it'll get you it look
like a father
I'm fine impressed with that
you